boom boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host style and sake
on very excited to be talking about
incentive systems design we have Ramon
Frey joining us on the show hello hey
thank you for having me
thanks for coming on really appreciate
it very happy to have you because your
work is so crucial at this pivotal
moment in time as we figure out these
and cents incentive systems design the
structures the frameworks resource flows
all this kind of stuff and for those who
don't know Ramon's background vermont's
has been in the Bay Area for 18 years
starting company starting organizations
he did an international art gallery for
10 years he also founded good people
dinners that links in the bio doing
meaningful conversations for the last 7
years 200 plus events have been hosted
there he's also partner at aah global
links also in the bio that's influencer
marketing we'd be talking about that a
bit and then also most recently he's
authoring a book called mount commerce
beginnings of incentives system design
awesome super pumped the medium also all
your writing a medium is really powerful
let's take this big history perspective
to start on civilization we find
ourselves as stewards of earth and
what's your current take on the
synthesis of the human experiment
well I think we're at a pivotal moment I
think for for most of our question it's
a big question but I think for most of
our history we have essentially not had
the tools to really understand the level
of interdependence of all of the life on
earth and our role in that
interdependent system and so in the last
couple hundred years we've developed the
ability first to understand it but that
understanding is uneven and secondly to
start to develop sort of the applied
science that we are living in the
Anthropocene we are now shaping not just
the geology but we're shaping the future
of all life on Earth and so in that kind
of scenario I think with this
accelerating levels of production
consumption extraction and an incentive
system that says simply more is better
we are at this pivotal moment where we
have to we have to grow up as a species
yes we actually have to embrace the
responsibility to come with all the
power that we've developed and to do
that a lot of fundamental things you're
going to have to change when I when I
think of the way that most people
approach so I I have quite a few friends
so I think this is dawned on them we
have all this power influence insight we
it's completely asymmetrical between us
and the other species on the planet now
what they tend to do is come up with
ways to remediate the damage so it's the
equivalent of saying here in San
Francisco cos there's a lot of homeless
people let's help them and that's
beautiful compassionate wonderful
impulse to have it's not very creative
and it's kind of obvious it's necessary
right but you're you're downstream
whereas the upstream thinker would go
and say why is our society constantly
producing people who don't have basic
resources yes in in a context there's so
much material access why are we
producing so many homeless people on our
streets shouldn't they at least
getting enough to survive so you can
apply that kind of thinking to
environmental stewardship you can apply
it to gender equality you could apply it
to education you could apply to all
kinds of things and so the book that I'm
working on I'm trying to help people to
think all the way upstream right and
maybe start new streams themselves where
certain incentives are not in opposition
to you know basic philanthropic impulse
so okay because when I take what you
just said and I bring it in to a
paraphrase what I think of and why a lot
of the reason why the show is called
simulation is because we're able to run
these thought-provoking simulations and
one of the ideas is that as you talked
about being upstream and talking about
the root of these issues we think about
how to make a simulation where
civilization didn't explode so quickly
in population and ignorant at the same
time as so much intelligence so that if
if there was just that slowdown of okay
we have a couple million people we're
gonna be training every single child
every single seed giving it the right
nutrients and watering that seed to
become its fullest potentials fullest
flower that we didn't have the the
issues that arose that the pressing the
reset button seeing that simulation
flourish I think is a very very
beautiful way of potentially seeing
things and also understanding how to get
to the root as you're saying and you do
think in that perspective Ron I know you
want to chime in there first yeah this
like this population it's and all these
people it's it's purposeful they knew
damn well that we needed this population
to create this world that we no longer
need all this population anymore so good
luck I'm just saying there's something
behind all
this that you know be fruitful and
multiply
go ahead since just to slow down to
think perspective at the same time and
and you know maybe it maybe towards
later we'll get to multidimensionality
later on and we'll dive into something I
think I think your point though is your
points well-taken in the sense that on
one level there's no quick fix and in a
culture of instant gratification and
conspicuous consumption anytime we're
faced with a challenge we want an
instantaneous fix and when you get to a
sort of systems level design of where
you would like to steer civilization you
realize yeah you got to start really
young and probably first and foremost is
just creating and this is up to parents
I mean this gets really foundational
creating emotional and psychological
safety for children yes and then all the
way through adulthood right the ability
to take a certain minimum standard I
mean you know I'm a friend of a Andrew
Yang who had on the show you don't take
a certain minimum standard of
subsistence and make that universal
because the the neurobiology of that
when you are constantly in fear for your
own basic needs and the basic needs of
everyone you love your frantic you
become you have a look you literally
express a lower IQ you you know you're
more prone to anger you're a worse
decision-maker you're less creative
you're less trusting you're less
cooperative you basically have a
diminished ability to manifest sort of
these like highest human potentials yeah
and so you know if you can create that
for a good 20 or 30 years if you could
remove the specter of constant war you
can create populations that I think
hypothetically would feel much more
secure and be able to manifest not just
twice as much maybe four or five times
as much of the human potential in the
world right you've heard the expression
you know a talent is evenly distributed
but opportunity isn't mm-hmm
and so by raising that floor on need
and distributing opportunity as widely
as possible you maximize the
manifestation of that human potential in
talent yeah and most people want to do
the right thing you know and then
there's there's a whole other
conversation like yeah how do you deal
with this small percentage of I mean we
should in every way disincentivize you
know incentivize pro-social and
disincentivize destructive yeah behavior
patterns and and we don't do a very good
job of that so now you're we're now
we're starting to wander into this so we
initially Illustrated this kind of like
this cool reset that one could do and
see how to slow down and think and
evolve to not even have these ailments
in the first place now we're talking
about reality that we live in which is
we have these ailments sure and now
we're talking about how to solve the
ailments in the most practical ways the
first way that you you know you
indicated this seed the seed of the mind
in the first you know six months or even
couple years is just such a crucial time
to have that love compassion basic
nutrients basic resources met for the
child being born into the world for them
to actually be able to maximize their
their fullest flourishing and when you
increase that baseline you enable all of
that talent and creativity to emerge and
that only requires hopefully a couple
decades potentially for it to be
completely enabled and it's in its
fullest and that that would be fantastic
now you also point out this really
fascinating thing to me to which is that
just the current incentive system that
we have in many ways has made so many
good things right here's the nuance we
have so many good innovations and
advancements that have occurred through
this incentive system but at the same
time you're also indicating that there
has been this lack of the fullest
creative potential unleash of so many
people still and and whatnot so let's
talk about then that the current
incentive system and how you perceive it
and then also the solutions that we have
so the so the initial problem so I I've
written the first draft of this book
which I'm tentatively calling Mount
Commerce the beginnings of incentive
system design
I like incentive systems because it's
more than simply economic inducements
those are extrinsic rewards and
extrinsic punishments we don't as human
beings operate in that simplistic away
we have social we have neurobiological
we have there's so many different ways
in which our behaviors are prompted
become habits and our manifest and so I
think when we think about diversifying
incentive systems we need to think about
all of these different aspects in
engineering and architecting them and
then we need to deploy them in these
little tiny experiments so we'll take a
few steps back there's a very popular
quote that's been going around from
Bucky fuller essentially to paraphrase
you don't change a system by operating
within that system or reforming it
essentially what you do is you try to
create new systems that render something
you find an unsatisfactory obsolete
right and so the course of you read
David Graeber book debt the first five
thousand years it's a wonderful polemic
which I think really broadens your
awareness of what incentive systems have
been the last 5,000 years systems of
Commerce credit debt those kinds of
things but in a really wonderful way it
gives you a sideways view across history
of enormous diversity of human incentive
systems there have been things that have
looked nothing like capitalism but have
included commerce that have existed in
different climates among different
peoples in isolated pockets all over the
world over the last 5,000 years and in
the last 300 to 500 years in my opinion
we've essentially either jettisoned or
assimilated almost all of that into
capitalism and capitalism is is now the
monoculture of Commerce
and a kind of tyranny and that that
monoculture runs by a very very simple
ethic right at which is very crude and
doesn't usually serve most people and
plant it well and that ethic is more is
better now an ethic of more is better
can produce staggering and accelerating
contexts of abundance it can raise pop I
mean I see over there you're Steven
Pinker's yes all right the better angels
of our nature right when you raise the
standard of living
using capitalism you do diminish
violence right you do raise standards of
living and the the quintessential story
of that is we lifted everyone out of
poverty and the rivers are poisoned okay
okay here's your new devastated
environment and everyone can eat steak
right and so that's that's the standard
and if we keep doing that and if we lift
everyone out of poverty that way which
isn't the only way yeah there will be on
a burnt-out husk of a planet like maybe
within my lifetime so I feel I feel a
lot of urgency about this drawing
people's attention to that monoculture
of capitalism demonstrating in the
course of the book using a bunch of
metaphors essentially there is there are
things we've thrown away and there's
room for invention so we can diversify
an experiment with incentives to get
into what kate ray worth was sort of an
intellectual hero of mine calls the
green the donut donut economics green
donut is her her graphical image and
that means operating essentially below
the ecological carrying capacity of the
earth not extracting more than it can
sustain but also raising the floor on
desperate need in poverty yeah so what
I'm what I'm advocating for is not just
raising the bottom of Maslow's hierarchy
but also compressing the top I think we
should go we should flip the script and
go from worshipping billion
as somehow demigods right there's this
perverse hangover from from Pradas the
Protestant work ethic which says your
material wealth is demonstrative of your
favor with God and therefore if you're a
billionaire you must have great wisdom
on everything hmm
ethics everything and you that throws
the humility out the window if everybody
comes up to you and is like this all the
[ __ ] time no one you go crazy
I would eat go builds up so fast I would
just all of us yeah we're just people
right yeah so so we need to stop
worshipping people for hoarding and
maybe call it that and maybe the
appropriate response to someone
accumulating that much wealth would go
from worship to concern yeah and maybe
what we need is something like a maximum
wage I mean who really needs to earn
more than 100 million bucks a year right
isn't that perverse enough if we compare
if we said that you're the maximum tax
bracket was a hundred percent not even
marginal everything you are over a
hundred percent maybe you get some say
in it but that goes into the Commons
everything over a hundred million a year
well at the same time there's a counter
which is that if the person's morals had
evolved to such a degree than they could
potentially be adequate at
redistributing that themselves and
that's a very interesting topic as well
to consider but but I just you have so
much more to shed keywording vast wealth
is best done in groups with with
egalitarian operational sort of
protocols so in other words now you're a
billionaire it's five years from now you
need the match and you asked me before
you heard later please keep me humble
yeah please keep me sane absolutely
right yes so I think in that context a
group of people operating like a
platform cooperative
right and ethics first platformers great
could could say all of this excess
wealth we will have debate right
I mean I'm government's supposed to do
this correct I'm I'm not so much I'm not
as hopeful about reviving old forms of
democracy
I am hopeful about inventing new forms
of demise I agree yeah very a lot of the
initial code of the intention right the
ethical intention right right so but but
with capitalism the problem is everyone
who is thriving in the current incentive
system tries to tell you a lie it is it
is such an elephant there it's such an
obvious lie everyone knows it but nobody
sees any practical like tangible way to
get away from it and that lie is this is
an any moral system we're Switzerland
Facebook is not a good thing or a bad
thing we're just trying to make a buck
ban and we're trying to serve our
customers right and that's not true
Facebook it's created a hyper reality
and now it's a blur where we're living
yeah in the facebook it's a reality
distortion field as we say here in the
Bay Area right but face if you want to
understand Facebook's ethics do it for
yourself look at the behaviors of the
organization look at all of the
resistance to anything that resembles
trust-busting or anti-monopoly efforts
by all of the tech giant's you you will
see the ethics visible they're the data
hoarding similar to the material goods
hoarding by many other people as well
and any any bit of taking the torch to
try and to try and burn off the bad
parts of the consumers consumptive
materialistic behavior is automatically
like that socialistic and then when you
have all the resources you got really
good PR see manufacturing public
sentiment is now a product on offer in a
way that is far more powerful than at
any point in human history if you've
read Thinking Fast and Slow which I saw
behind you by kata me
you know once you apply that like
nudge-nudge once you apply the insights
of behavioral economics if you have
sufficient budget and sufficient insight
into a particular target demographic you
can get them to vote in a particular way
you can get them to live on [ __ ]
Snickers bars and so one of the you know
one of the things I try to meddling
right yeah well yeah we are all coercing
one another constantly and it goes even
deeper than that we are we are
profoundly shaping one another in terms
of our own identities individually in
His grace constantly yes so if you can
get comfortable with seeing that as a
reality which is what's in my opinion
happening yeah I think you can start to
get comfortable saying you know what man
I I think I think more people should be
kale so I'm gonna put that on the top
shelf
sure I'm not gonna take away the
Snickers bar but it's gonna be hard to
find
sure right sure and and kale will be
grown so abundantly that and it will be
delivered to you by drone slash bot
whatever you want to say and it's just
so make it easy easy easy easy do the
healthy it's free great but he's it
easier yeah I mean I'm joking with kale
yeah it's like this like it's a symbol
of healthy home but you can do that for
thoughts to you yeah you can make it
easier to find high-value knowledge
exact harder to find derp content that
has a very vapid I'm sorry vaping okay
there's too many cool things to unpack
okay let's start with the globe behind
your head okay so you started with this
this really cool way of understanding
that the it's we do every it's a union
we have a union it's a unity on this
planet we are one with the planet the
plants the animals the insects the other
humans here and
their amount of extraction that's
happening from both people's souls in
time as well as from the resources of
the planet for for greed and excess is
it's it's it's the egregious the ethics
of more is better says do whatever you
can to accelerate the pace and volume of
transaction full stop if you could get a
thousand people a day to come through
your restaurant and throw all the food
in the garbage great you're winning
right as long as they pay you as long as
they pay the food is in the garbage
sure capitalism incentivizes what I just
described to subscribe yeah right
doesn't say let's make sure every
calorie nourishes someone if that would
be a different incentive system okay so
so a lot of what we're talking about and
there's still so much more to unpack on
what you were just saying but a lot of
what we're talking about is we have this
the current incentive system design and
there's portion that's great
incentivizing innovation eradicating
poverty excellent excellent
on this other aspect of the incentive
design of the current ecosystem we have
some malevolence some egregious
behaviors let's say now the one that
you're illustrating is this new
incentive design and on that one we're
trying to take the good code from the
old one continuing to incentivize
innovation continuing to identify the
eradicating poverty the good stuff and
we're trying to eradicate the malevolent
side of it and we're trying to maybe
keep people in stronger we're trying to
actually have more of the variables
computed for the most ecologically
friendly right community friendly yeah
so what I would the way I would phrase
it is this so some people when they hear
some of the things I say they're like
this guy's communist or something I'm an
entrepreneur they're nothing lights me
up like hey man let's start business or
hell it started or organization or not
profit or something I get so excited
that even when I'm just hanging out
having fun with friends we're constantly
jokingly inventing businesses and
companies the other day we had like a
two-hour laughing till we were crying
conversation about a whole new animated
series called combat wombat why cause it
rhymed and I just loved wombats they're
adorable
right so this is like part of my DNA
here's what happened that hurt every
year that went by you know I've had some
modest successes I haven't had no
runaway successes but I've had plenty of
friends who have every year that went by
I found it harder and harder to start
again if you came to me or like hey I
got an idea what if we did this and I
was like why is it allons nice guy why
is it that I'm not sight even if his
idea is good that I'm not psyched to do
it and what I realized was think of it
this way the monoculture the global
Leviathan of capitalism where everyone
it's like swimming this river or die of
thirst hmm take it or leave it right
mm-hmm
every idea you have even if it's a
benefit corporation or a nonprofit or an
NGO or a small business or something
that could become a huge business is in
that sandbox and every year that goes by
more people pee in the sandbox and I
don't want to play there anymore they're
poisoning the river that's arrived we're
swimming in so so I'm sorry I love
playing in the sandbox
right and one day I just woke up after
dumping nuclear waste yeah right but I
wake up and I'm like I can't it's not
that on one it's not I'm not taking a
virtuous stand I can't play in this
sandbox
it's gross what do I do yeah my only
option is to imagine other sand boxes
that make the old one obsolete yeah
mostly mostly there will always be
capitalists I've died in the world
capitalists in the world but if I got to
die in a world
oh you know we have to just make it
clear that we can make we can illustrate
in a way that takes the even lots of
people from that are better enjoy the
old infrastructures and get them given
the good
and an easy bridge to the new ones yeah
yeah you can still be an entrepreneur
you can still have profit motive yes
you know but this new system it's gonna
be hard to impossible to become a
billionaire but you could have such
opulence of material who [ __ ] cares
after 10 million bucks really right like
it's just then it's just the ego right
Maura Lorenzo de'medici she's still my
favorite example of this five hundred
years ago in Italy in Florence where he
had so much wealth and he patron
Michelangelo and and so this is what I'm
talking about is why doesn't the wealth
just go to the excess just go directly
to the entrepreneurs and artists to help
them so okay it we don't have time for
this great it's funny you bring up the
DG because I have a previous life
I left the art world seven or eight
years ago but I have a previous life in
art yeah and I can tell you that elite
art as it is experienced by collectors
museums museum visitors auction houses
auction house patrons elite art today is
horrible for a very specific reason it
has simply become an unregulated
securities market the would-be Medicis
right III the the perfect movie for this
it was a recent HBO movie called the
price of everything right in the second
half of that expression is the value of
nothing the value of art is horribly
lost in the morass of profit motive oh
yeah I left art because nobody gave a
[ __ ] about cars or or inspiration
they're like is this a good investment
and what you realize when you get into
the art yeah what you get when you get
into elite art and elite art maybe up
here and you may have wonderful idealist
down at the bottom but it's aspirational
they're all pointing this way and and a
tiny percentage get there and then
they're like oh [ __ ] this is what it's
about right they realized that they're
just playthings in an unregulated
securities market so if you want
you're saying capitalism I wrote a
chapter about this in the book if you
want to understand capitalism at its
most raw without regulations without
controls look at the art world right it
it just turns everything into an ROI and
when you become obsessive that way you
treat your spouse that way you treat
your kids that way you treat your
friendships you don't understand why all
this money and power hasn't brought you
love and respect damn the translation of
that to your family and to your friends
the presiding ethic it becomes a
presiding I think and it's in in this in
the sense that you're painting it's just
made it so that yeah art lost the
component of ah it lost more integrity
integrity right so think of emotional
and intellectual integrity if I could
snap my fan antiquities antiquities
trafficking's like the fourth largest
it's great wait art is a great way to
launder money art is a great way to like
but but you're destroying artifacts of
civilization for us to better
manufacture scarcity because it makes
your thing more valuable so you know and
syndicate behaviors are not illegal
either pump-and-dump
behaviors that would get that are
supposed to get you in jail if you did
them with securities are completely the
norm in the art world right and so so
the art world is emblematic of this all
markets work this way but what we do is
we push back to try to minimize those
excessive behaviors and in the course of
my life I think we've failed I think we
mostly fail all the pushing back and the
regulation and regressive taxation as
the velocity of money and the
impediments to its movement around the
world continuously diminished right and
the speed picks up money just moves so
all of the thinking that any nation even
the United States right that's why at
the end of thomas piketty's book capital
in 21st century he says we need a
non-porous global tax regime which i
think is nuts but damn non-poor so money
can't do no place to hide
yeah everybody makes the same taxes
globally we speak as one you know global
civilization and say you know and we
create that I that seems insane to me
but I understand the impulse and I think
the insights I think his yeah yeah it's
a very very big picture long now
perspective on civilization a lot of
people also argue that these little
city-states populating in people
deciding with their own lifetimes and
money where to go play etc those will
become the big one
eventually but we got all get all the
whole the whole world is more likely to
look like the city-states like Venice
and Renaissance Italy you know I mean I
see that argument yeah but and and maybe
like a little Hong Kong or Singapore
these pockets the Dubai the special
economic zones these things yeah but
these are all different forms these are
these are these are experiments in
rigging capitalism to benefit an elite
in my opinion sure sure right like I was
watching there's a comedian remember
Harold and Kumar so one of the comedians
I'm forgetting his name right now he
just did a series on Netflix like the
global the big global beast that is
capitalism or something like sure and he
talks he does this thing all about Dubai
and how do you buy we just said we would
love to support your business in every
way but you have to let an Emirati own
51% and and it worked dish for a while
right and now they're kind of they're
getting external pressure to maybe drop
that okay yeah we get let's yeah let's
let's come let's come back to the to the
one that Kieran going can I ask a
question yes about the arts Ramon what
do you think of Basquiat and do you
think his work had the merit or was he
an artist just because he knew Andy
Warhol what's your thoughts so there
have been these turning points in the
last hundred years
where are I we're visual art I think
went wrong I think any Warhol started
off as a pretty idealistic and
altruistic artist like like most artists
and know everyone ignored him and then
he became a profound cynic and he became
rich and famous and I think pretty
miserable and everyone looked at that
and said the market rewards with money
and attention profound cynicism read
some Andy Warhol's writing write from A
to B and back again [ __ ] like that like
he was a cynical bitter person and and
one and so every artist looked to that
and said that's how to win and it's been
getting worse and worse ever since
Basquiat got caught up in that - he was
part of that circle you know why were
these people so much in pain maybe some
of it was their past but maybe some of
it was their present and the cynicism
that developed right I mean as far as I
could tell and he's in that HBO
documentary Jeff Koons as far as I can
tell he might be a sociopath he is the
apotheosis of Andy Warhol's cynicism
Warhol still hurt Koons doesn't hurt
he's just maximizing his own benefit
from the maximum commodification of
creativity right did I answer your
question yes in depth I mean there's a
artists out there who are rich and you
can you can just feel how deeply in
anguish they are because they know that
their success is just feeding art and
driving it in the wrong direction it's
driving it away the for David Foster
Wallace I didn't say the same thing
about the conspicuous consumption of the
boats and the house doors and the sad
rest of sports cars all that kind of
stuff the the supermodels with bikinis
champagne and all this kind of you gotta
try it
know how insecure as Obama recently said
does it have to be in order to need
eight women twerking around them I mean
how ridiculous would this be to see
wealthy women with eight men in thongs
twerking around
or in campaign I hope more people will
see how ridiculous it is and how these
people have hearts they have souls they
have talent they've flourished potential
I want we have to do this again because
there's too much cool stuff to unpack
and it's really interesting seeing your
background come to light here too with
art yeah because I actually didn't see
it in this lens you shed a lot of cool
light on how art actually had its own
parasitic poisons poured into it that
made the decrease in awe and increase in
money and greed and and and wealth that
took away from the actual purpose of it
all so this is seen all around us in
just the way that we have more like
we're you're saying there but there's so
many so much sadness and anxiety and
depression suicidal thoughts and yeah
and decreases in intimate relationships
ability to look at people in the eye and
and and show them that love and care and
compassion ethics of capitalism is you
are a means to my ends you are a means
to my ends whatever my ends maybe maybe
I want to get laid I don't want money
you're a means to my ends and you can
feel that when someone's treating you
that way if they're a little more savvy
you know what they do first they say let
me help you fulfill your ends so that
there's reciprocity but it's still a
relationship completely confined to the
transactional only but it doesn't need
to be that binary it doesn't the extreme
extreme yeah right so but there's plenty
of people that approach and say like let
me help and then sure they help and then
you help back and then you also talk
about things like their family and their
values and how you can help them and you
then it's a spectrum right yeah exactly
and so at one end is the person who
treats you purely that way and the other
end is the person who's completely opted
out right yeah it's like somebody who
takes ordination in the seminary or
something like that right could could
potentially be something like that yeah
that I wanted to just say one last thing
about the art thing okay for David
Foster Wallace killed himself he said
the I'm paraphrasing the most radical
thing an artist can do now is single
entendre right be completely sincere as
an artist is totally revolutionary for
our time because every artist is just
burying themselves in a well in one of a
few ways either I'll give I'll just
create pure consistent product or they
are burying themselves in cleverness and
double triple quadruple entendre of
meaning yeah right and so and I think he
was right I think I think all the arts
should take that look and go get back to
that place of emotional and intellectual
enteric integrity and total sincerity
yeah and say you know what my arts about
it's exactly about what I think and feel
about this world yeah right and I think
people would rally to that kind of art
right if that is the ultimate it's
that's the ultimate way to be an artist
as an agent in the world is to be your
ultimate most expression each moment in
time to the next it just dropped fully
into it so I just want to kind of close
that loop on Sam because that applies to
everyone now even the ones that have
accumulated so much radical wealth is
that the loss and humility of the
propping up an ego and worship and I
want on the boat so I'm gonna do
everything possible to get on yeah
become the path to dignity right like
it's like when you go to the bar and for
like a half hour you're trying to get
the bartender and the bartenders
completely ignoring you on purpose
oh yeah yeah and and so yourself it
seems like this and then finally they
give you a beer right and many of you're
lucky and you keep paying for that yeah
you know you should you paying for it
after 30 year time after 30 seconds
leave the bar go to the bar where the
bartender it's like hey man I'm gonna
get you in just a sec I'm so glad you're
here you're here Yeah right I'm gonna
treat you with respect the art world
doesn't do this the art world is also
kind of an extreme place where you you
condescend
to the person to such an extreme that
you drop their self-esteem and you let
them buy their dignity back through the
piece of art right and again there's
parallels in all kinds of things it's
it's I think kind of obvious in fashion
it's kind of obvious in these sort of
vanity things yeah we but it's in
everything we need to we need to get
over the multi-hundred dollar t-shirt
era buy your dignity Bravo yeah bye yeah
it's there's a radical wholeness that
that comes from from humility and
gratitude for just being on earth and
having great people around you okay
because we need it we need to talk about
this how does the the distributed ledger
how does watching technology come into
play for the new incentive system design
think so yeah so so since leaving the
art world in 2012 I've done a lot of
work in the startup ecosystem here in
the Bay Area some advisories some
consultant occasional take an in-house
role or I become a co-founder a little
over a year ago maybe a year and a half
ago I was invited to do a simple few
facilitations that I've developed over
the years for a startup and they could
pay me cash which was nice thank you
better than private stock and so we went
into this process and they loved it
then I was offered a part-time gig then
I was offered a full-time role which I
took and then I was offered to become
full partner and this all happened super
fast and we raised a lot of money really
quickly mostly in cryptocurrency which
we all know how that's thing I was very
excited inspired by this for a variety
of reasons one this organization was a
benefit corporation focused on ESG
impact environmental social and
governance impact so they were gonna
take and I'm going to answer your
questions say they were going to take
blockchain and use its ability to create
crypto currencies to try to maximize the
positive effect on the environment and
on social and governance impact
outcomes so so it was a wild ride
incredible I was out of that back you
know hug yes last year September
something like that and that gets me to
the second reason I got really excited
about watching and I've written a lot
about this there's a fair bit of it in
the book I just put together but
essentially the industry got co-opted
because you could invent your own native
digital currency it got co-opted by an
out-of-control frenzy of hype greed
speculation fraud scams and that's a
tragedy because there's a more
altruistic application which pretty much
nobody's doing because it's not a
get-rich-quick scheme which can
radically reinvent governance the
distribution the exercise of power the
ability to direct and incentivize the
flows of money and it can be everywhere
and nowhere right so what does that mean
that means that and I'm just speaking
about the currency part I'm not talking
about the other things that an indelible
digital ledger can do because when you
talk about that for four hours mm-hmm
the the currency part right now the
dollar has value because we all agree it
does the word glass has meaning because
we all agree it does that's a very
important realization the dollars value
is backed by our government we believe
in our government which is another very
powerful fiction that helps us all
cooperate right I know you've all know
what Harari works on well it talked
about this quite a lot and so we all
believe in this dollar and it's pegged
to the legitimacy of this government
there is no logical reason we cannot peg
the value of a digitally native currency
to real-time data about the health of
the biosphere yeah for instance there's
no reason we can't peg a native digital
currencies value and use to educational
outcomes for women globally
right there's no reason we can't do
these things these are hard things to do
yeah right so teach us about how that's
designed to work the easiest way for me
to kind of unpack this for people is not
by getting into the technicalities
because truth be told we would run into
the limits of my own knowledge as well
the way to invent to architect and
deploy alternative incentive systems is
to do it collaboratively among a group
of experts and that's one of my
aspirations to what I want to happen
after the book can you give us an
abstract of how it would work yes that's
what I'll do so in the book I talk about
meeting these two friends who work at
the Nature Conservancy Barbara and Steph
and we gotten to me just slipped in this
conversation hours went by and by the
end of the conversation we realized we
had thought of something no one has ever
done it was exciting and intimidating
and that would be there was a particular
fish in village now this fishing
villages economy is linked to the health
of the local fishery if they over fish
it which are always tempted to do it
will collapse and so will their local
economy right and so the nature
consumers you've been working for a long
time in this village with people who
live there on the ground trying to
figure out essentially how do we create
an economics of temperance moderation in
the relationship between the village and
the fishery yes right yes they are
working on ways to get real-time flows
of reliable data on the diversity and
quantity of fish so imagine those data
flows go into a little gamified app on
everyone's phone in the town the better
the fishery does the more cryptocurrency
they get right the cost of that
cryptocurrency we issue that
cryptocurrency it's not very much if
they develop the dap you have to make
sure it's secure it's not you have to
think through like if you're a black hat
hacker how might you would exploit this
sure but you peg that currency to the
health of the fishery and the real-time
data coming in right there's little
sensors on the boats all kinds of stuff
maybe there's satellite data and so
anytime they launch the app they see in
real time how that fish
yeah so there's peer pressure now right
they're getting an extension of the
essence of the health of the fit health
of the fishery and here's free money
okay fishery is doing poorly free money
let goes down yeah but then don't they
find another way to exchange value if
they don't have the cryptocurrency that
so the way I'm doing this my way visit
so the way we had imagined it is there's
that relationship that the value of the
currency and the distribution of the
currency for this little experiment
within a tiny geographical area and a
limited amount of time is pegged and
then we have we open shop with staples
that that the people in the town tell us
they they normally use this little shop
will accept say Mexican pesos but it
will also accept our cryptocurrency now
it now the cryptocurrency has gone from
just an abstraction to something that's
useful for material goods and the hope
would be to seed with youth the
entrepreneurial spirit to seed a new
micro economy because maybe someone up
the street who washes cars says I'll
accept fish coin or whatever we call it
nature coin right and we try different
ways of seeding that local economy and
we can get real-time data and analytics
on how it's working or what's going
wrong or why did it collapse right and
if it does the town shouldn't be any
worse off than it was the beginning yeah
and if it takes off maybe we try it with
a fishing village in the Philippines but
maybe we have to adjust it for the
culture there or just deliver them clean
meat grown in bioreactors as soon as
possible you know I'm always thinking
that way
and I'm very interested to unpack the
ways of designing this incentive system
using distributed ledger technology that
I think has a lot of potential and like
you were explaining there's micro
deployments and then there's a global
deployments which are which I'm I'm
really looking forward to what it can it
can do I think another thing on top of
like doing something like delivering
clean meat across the world is another
thing is just the sincere self work that
if humans just did a better job at a
prioritizing sincere software parents
teaching kids that community
he's teaching kids that and just really
working on that from the seed level of
just tuning in word reflecting morally
and ethically evolving we wouldn't have
the parasitic poisonous roots poisoning
the rivers and doing things like the
over fishings and all that kind of stuff
but there's yeah you know vectors of
failure on that I mean it takes a tiny
number of people acting very very badly
to ruin it for everyone so you know I
recently had a conversation with Robert
Sapolsky and I think the reason he took
some time with me because I said Robert
what I read your chapter and behave on
game theory there are many many many
ways to incentivize sociologically
economically biologic everything to
incentivize freeloaders bullies thieves
a lot of bad behavior there's a much
narrow set of ways to incentivize
altruism altruism I would like to talk
to you about how we might architect
incentive systems that optimize for
altruism yes correct
yeah so and I took a bunch of notes in
it it does really will require that deep
moral ethical framework for every seed
that comes in to want to play
altruistically because others play
altruistic lee and if you're birthed
into that world and there's hopefully up
to certain putting no bad actors which I
think some of the social credit system
is actually causing in itself is the
removal of bad actors period so which is
very amazing this is nothing we're not
just talking sesame credit in China
people think that that's what people
talk about we're talking about [ __ ]
Twitter and YouTube and all of the
platforms here they're doing the exact
same thing if you're not following your
becomes censored and that's it what do
you do have grab attention your and then
you get censored from the payment
platforms as well and when you get
kicked off the payment platforms then
there's no way for you to earn money
what do you what are you incentivizing I
think so you know who solved for this in
a wonderful way I'm reading a book right
now called moral origins by Christopher
Bayne and about 15,000 years ago human
tribal culture solved beautifully for
this but they solved for it at the scale
of say 20 to 50 individuals and and so
there's there's I think
strong evidence that they were fiercely
egalitarian they were actually extremely
non hierarchical they were very
different for instance from baboons and
the reason we were that way back then is
we learned to hunt animals that were
bigger than us hmm
and we all benefited from that fat
content and our prefrontal cortex got
thicker right and there's no way you
alone no matter how strong you are gonna
take a mask it correct yeah it required
10 to 20 and setting it rookie together
and then it but if you dealt the killing
blow you're gonna you have really
tempted to become the alpha male that's
right and what happens in those contexts
is everyone shames you horribly and the
meat is taken away from you and and so
this is still seen in a lot of
hunter-gatherer tribes in present day
right and if you still got really
arrogant and uppity and hortie right we
would banish you which was almost as bad
as death right and if you were still
proudful in those contexts we murdered
you I know but I'm just thinking that
the stick right just to put you know you
called it a maximum wage earlier or
there's like the other one which is to
to be like you know you're buying your
fifth house where you know we're not
we're censoring or whatever made out of
the banishment it's just the evolution
of the ethics and the morals from
internally to not even desire to to get
the next threat seventh property or
whatever that - cycle that money to
artisan you can let it happen you don't
have to go full prohibitive and you
don't have to go genocide all you but
you what you can do is you can const
imagine an incentive system that brings
more meaning it's the big thing that's
really what well Matt see not everyone
wants more meeting in their life so
imagine an incentive system that
constantly drives wealth to the middle
that's not what we have now hmm and
regret and and and regressive taxation
that's a post facto way to try to solve
for that mmm right it's not built into
the systems that drive wealth to the
middle correct correct correct and to a
light lift
Yeah right yeah I guarantee there's an a
brilliant minds in the world that if
they heard the words I just said could
invent that correct I'm writing about
that as part of what I'm working on
right now it's it's it's in we're in the
same ballpark this is why we have to
have another show to talk about this in
more depth it's it's these incentive
systems are the solutions to some of the
poison that we have poured by accident
into the river II hear that you're the
three existential guy Daniel SH Martin
burger he talks about the generator
functions of existential risk here are
the three things that are suicide in
capitalism as it exists
hyper-consumption we calibrate for that
that's infinite GDP growth on a finite
planet is suicide in my opinion we're
not going to like some have D
materialize our way out of that a wealth
polarization more and more poor people
slight uptick in rich people no more
middle class that's also suicidal that
that always ends like the Bolshevik
Revolution always of a species
bifurcation it always happens and then
the tragedy of the Commons so those are
the things that I solve for here are the
two things that are super hard see I
hope this book leads to a foundation
where we get to architect and deploy
experiments that's right and I want
really smart people to join me when I
eventually get there I hope people who
know lots of things I don't you know the
first experiment will never get out the
door so I hope some people will join me
we will keep doing this yes so but the
the two things to solve for which are
super hard and is a challenge I offer to
everybody is calibrating for altruism
how do we deploy little experiments to
where in every way people are rewarded
for altruistic behaviors and hoarding
behaviors or psychopathic behaviors and
I would argue psychopathic behaviors are
heavily rewarded in capitalism because
when you detach empathy right and you're
able to go robotic and have a firewall
right that's an advantage that is a
strategic competitive advantage
capitalism right you're you're more if
at the very very top of the Fortune 100
incidences psychopathy is higher than in
the general population by a lot because
it's because it's an asset right
what would an economy look like if there
was a much higher incidence of altruism
at the top of that economy how do we
calibrate for that so the first one is
how do we calibrate for altruistic
behaviors yeah and then the second is
how do we create an economic that
calibrates for modesty and consumption a
temperance economics right so that
you're really disincentivized to hyper
consume and hoard and you're really and
it's almost impossible to wallow in
abject poverty anywhere on earth yes
right so how do we build those things
yeah that's what I want that's the main
thing I want then we'll all just be full
of [ __ ]
[Music]
through some sort of capital gain sure
no no no run you're making a good point
which is there is a very poisonous way
to architect this which will leave
everyone full of [ __ ]
then there's then there's there's a very
interesting way to architect it which is
when you come from a place of self work
when everyone desires to be altruistic
themselves without even if the incentive
systems in play or not then the inside
the system being in play makes it even
more fun to put its accelerant for the
best the best angels of every person's
nature yeah right we're gonna fuel that
because right now we often are fueling
some of the people's worst impulses
right if children learn through
imitation and trial and error right and
I'll for example I remember when I was a
kid here I learned I learned walk into
the room fake it to you make it with
bravado and suddenly everyone will fall
in the line and you know you're not as
smart as these six people you just were
like ballsy right and and so there's
there
a lot of perverse incentives there right
and a lot of that has to do with being a
white dude and the privilege that comes
with it you know the same kind of
strategy might not have worked if I've
been born into a different body we're
passing down the the cultural systems to
the next generation and and we got to
rethink and rethink the incentive
systems design this has been such a
fascinating conversation
so multivariate this is I love it I love
sure I think I mean I'm excited for
another for another round but quickly on
the way out you know you're talking
about altruism
I do think you know eventually we'll
also talk about like influencer
marketing in age Global and stuff I
think it's very interesting to
potentially have we were talking about
this to have these high-stake
influencers desire to be involved in
more propagating more of the altruistic
small dogs yeah I want it I wouldn't so
my role as a partner eh level my
aspiration for the company if you look
on the website you'll see big fortune
100 clients like coca-cola like you
mentioned and you know I don't see how
you are an altruistic company when
you're obviously contributing to a
explosion of diabetes right so I would
like to drive our business in the
direction of people who are propagating
ultra sick behaviors we're driving
people towards healthy behaviors yes
we're doing all of those kinds of things
so those are the kind of clients and
influencers I'm looking for for that
company we're excited to they should put
their coat back and coke like they did
before whatever it is in that nowadays
absolutely can okay - two quick
questions on the way this is simulation
so we must ask you are we continuation I
saw you do this with Andrew yang so I
thought about it
so might might you know first thought
best thought Suzuki Ricci you know it
doesn't matter on one level on another
level and we don't have time for this I
thought about the Fermi paradox Drake's
equation and technology yeah if you if
you look at the arc of technological
progress and you extrapolate
all technologies essential greater and
greater control and a adapting matter
and time and space to our preference so
at an exponential curve what does that
mean that means we get to invent
universes according to our preferences
yes right like literally if there's such
a thing as the multiverse maybe
civilizations invent other universes and
can navigate to any place in space or
time within that universe so that's one
wild extrapolation it's a good premise
for a science-fiction story The Fairly
paradox and Drake's equation talk about
where and where are all the alien
civilizations and my opinion there we
had a guy at one of my good people
dinners a good friend Greg delery runs a
private space company called Helio space
he was a prophet Berkeley and he they
build instrumentation and and sensors
and things that go out into our solar
system so they have like NASA contracts
and things like that and he came and
talked about it the way I think about
that is civilizations have life spans
just like individual organisms and what
we're watching now with technological
development is imagine you handed out a
red button to every living person and
said if you press it all life ends and
then every decade or century you give
them another button with the same power
right so the vectors of civilizational
suicide proliferate and distribute yes
which means statistically speaking and
as all civilizations end mmm and I think
there's a good chance that's true and I
will like fight like hell to help us
figure this out yeah that may be our
roles in this in this game but then look
we may just stand ourselves anyway that
was a very strong strong synthesis very
very strong okay and because we'll riff
on that more next time and the last
question that we asked on the show what
is the most beautiful
in the world this beautiful thing in the
world you know there's two answers to
that for me um you know being with
someone you deeply love and respect
where that's reciprocated so for me that
the person that gives my daughter I'm
just a better larger person when I'm
with her and then the other thing is you
know connecting to the natural world I
was yesterday I was up in Lawson
volcanic national park it's like more
snow I think it's the most no I've ever
seen like in my life and they plow all
the way up to the visitors center and
then after that it's closed I can show
you these photos it's it was it's it's
total ecstasy just to like be there and
look around and walk around and snowshoe
and yeah and it's and it's humbling you
know 20 to 40 foot walls of snow you
know it's pretty amazing
I was impressed that the Visitor Centre
could carry the weight of the snow I saw
on the roof it was almost completely
buried right like they have to shovel
out so I guess you don't suffocate when
you're inside there and it's a giant
building yeah
those are those are powerful there's
there's something profound about getting
the young people that are building the
future to pass more time with children
because then they can feel that essence
of that youth and really have a greater
stewardship I think for for earth mom
what a freaking pleasure decided yeah
yeah we have we have another show we'll
have to schedule together soon let's
let's make sure let's make it happen
thank you again
such a wealth of wisdom super excited
for for more conversation soon everyone
we would love to hear your thoughts on
the episode give us your thoughts in the
comments below also check out all the
links below
good people dinners age Global also
check out her mom's website he's got
tons of great writing assets on his
medium check that out that links below
as well also huge shout out to Ron
Vargas for producing and directing we
love you so much thank you thank you Ron
and everyone support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in go and
support them help them grow help them
prosper and flourish our links are below
if you believe in us support us help us
grow and manifest your dreams into the
world build create execute we love you
so much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you